this video is sponsored by raycon winter
2021 has absolutely reminded me why i
love being an anime fan attack on titan
making its mark on pop culture jiu jitsu
kaisen just getting better and better
with every episode horimia being the
most wholesome thing on this planet
wondering
cutting deep into my psyche and then
there's redo of a healer
airing a hentai car crash but when i was
picking which one of these shows i
really wanted to talk about the most
i kept coming back to michoacatense
jobless reincarnation the isakai of the
season oh [ __ ]
if you're new to this channel here hi
there i like izakaya yes
even the bad ones and my relationship
with the genre with this channel goes
something along the lines of all right
guys it's time to talk about another
easter guy oh god no
please i know you're bored of me talking
about isekai i'm bored of me talking
about isekai but after a relatively
quiet 2020 for new titles in the genre
mushoka tensei has come along and i
believe
has shown how truly special this genre
can be
so i'm going to talk about this rudius
greyrat is a newly born baby entering a
fantasy world who after appreciating his
mum's rack realizes he's just a baby and
his first words after entering this
world were
to them rudy is actually a 34 year old
man with his memory still intact he's
been reincarnated after he died when he
where was the plot point again
got hit by a truck because of this his
family haven't realized that they've
given birth to a baby permanently horny
on main but
as he grows up he soon realizes that
he's not the only one that's horny this
is dad
he's basically a hentai protagonist he's
horny there's his mom she goes at it
with his dad a lot because she's horny
there's his maid
she's horny too the general population
of this world they're pretty horny
eventually he gets a teacher who's
actually relatively normal nothing more
to say about her just kidding she's
ultra horny and thus
begins rudy's second life as he slowly
grows older
learns about the magic and this new
world and discovering the wonders of
roxy's panties you could make a religion
out of this now for those of you who
don't know more this may seem like a
very generic plot synopsis for you and
you may be wondering what about this
plot separates it from
every other izakaya that you've seen
yes around here in the sky corner
mushoka tensei is often touted as the
grandfather of modern isekai
or the grandmother or the father or the
alcoholic uncle who shows up at family
parties and makes inappropriate comments
about his niece popularized but a lot of
tropes you've seen them on an iso guy
anti-social nerd gets killed you've got
a fantasy world with magic [ __ ] you even
get to see trucking during his intern
phase
not to be that guy but i mean following
trucking since he was underground always
knew he was going to blow up but i mean
it's easy to say that a piece of work is
a pioneer genre and yet still age badly
if the once original tropes it pioneered
have become tied cliches but somehow
mushoka ten says one of those few easter
guys i've watched where the tropes you
recognize in it makes sense
cause one of the biggest questions i've
always wondered is why do isekai
need to be isekai with a lot of early
stories in these genres it would always
follow the adventures of these
characters trying to find a way back to
their own world
12 kingdoms now and then here and there
even [ __ ] digimon
there was a reason for these shows to be
isakai because the main motivating plot
point was to find a way
back but eventually this notion
disappeared completely characters would
have no interest in returning to their
previous world and instead the main
reason for a story to become an isakai
was
hey you are you a loser who needs a
blank protagonist to project on well
look at this blank projection of a loser
nerd who's actually good looking
talented and smart but don't worry about
that because he's a loser
just like you and now he's in a new
world where he has sexy singles in his
area and he's completely op
because of this one simple trick that
makes every bad guy hate him
that's right it's everything you could
ever hope for so jump in front of a
truck today and get transported to the
world of your dreams call 1-800 kill me
now to book your next truck driver
act now and we'll even throw in a free
lolly and all this time i've always
wondered how the [ __ ] did we get from
point
a to point b and watching this made me
realize that
mushoka tensei might have been that
missing link this entire time
rudy was an unpopular anti-social
shot-in in his previous life he was
bullied he has social anxiety
he has trauma and this led him to shut
himself off from the world and become
the person he was he's an ugly worthless
low life of society who did nothing or
david watch anime play video games and
jack off to hentai i mean look at this
guy
is this the hero you'd like to project
yourself on an ugly bastard who can't
even find a role in a hentai i bet he
even moderates a discord server these
experiences and the person he was
isn't just magically changed because he
was reborn in a fancy world he carries
the trauma of his previous life he's
really
really horny because he's obviously
never had a love life and views girls
like there are love interests in the
eurogas he used to play he's not the
perfect bastian of righteousness like
every other escape protagonist but what
he does have now
is a loving family people who are
willing to give him a chance and an
opportunity to start over
the person he was before he is
reincarnated isn't just ignored and
forgotten about in fact it constantly
plays an active part in shaping the kind
of person he becomes in this world
he wants to become a better person
because of the person he was before
not in spite of it there's an actual
reason for this isakai
to be a [ __ ] iso guy not to say that
this is the first isekai to ever refer
to a protagonist's previous life but it
definitely feels like this one had the
biggest effect
and starts right from the get-go the
tropes and cliches you might recognize
aren't just tropes and cliches as much
as they are just core elements that
build on the plot
characters or world they are not just
surface level writing prompts there's a
reason why they are there looking at
rudy as a character
i know there's going to be a fair chunk
of people get put off by rudy's behavior
but i think that's kind of the point
even if there are some things he does
that
even i'm not gonna stand here and try
and defend like i don't know where on
the legality scale a guy with 30 years
of memories trapped in a child's body
essentially raising his love interest
from a young age to become his perfect
wife in the future stands but
it awfully sounds like a word that
rhymes with schlooming
that is generally illegal and or frowned
upon in most places in the world i'm
just waiting for this to be the next
thing that twitter hate more picks up
but look
i'm not saying what he does is
justifiable at all or that there aren't
some really weird things that happen
every now and then
that guy really just tell an
eight-year-old kid to use protection can
everyone in this show for a second just
but what i am saying is that you don't
have to support all of a main
character's actions nor condone
everything that happens
to appreciate a good fictional story
through all of rudy's actions you can
sincerely see him trying to become a
better person
the more experiences he has in his new
life the more he realizes he doesn't
have to be like that person he was
before
we get to see him not just grow in age
all over again but as a person as well
and come on guys who doesn't love a good
redemption arc but he's not the only one
either
for example his dad is basically an
ex-harem protagonist and kind of a
sleazeback who does some really uncool
things but he does try to be his best to
be a good father and set a good example
for his son even if he can't be that
perfect role model himself
and then there's eris she's kind of a
little [ __ ]
the real magic of the show comes in the
care that's been put into the characters
and this world they envelop there's
nothing particularly special
about the settings or the concepts you
can just feel the attention to detail
being put into
every aspect of this story every single
character feels like a living breathing
part of this world
rather than just a buggy oblivion npc
there to just fill the space
if this is catching your interest and
you're just waiting for me to get to
that one
big plot hook to get you invested well
there kind of isn't one right now
alright so i wrote that line and the
corresponding paragraph a few weeks ago
before the big plot hook
did happen so um that really completely
[ __ ] up my next point
because what i was going to say is that
some may see the series as a bit of a
slow burn since especially at the
beginning not
a lot really happens a lot of it is just
rudy living his life and growing up
at times it can feel more like a slice
of life but it set up its foundation so
well
that i was already incredibly invested
in these characters and the world
and now that there has been a big
turning point in the series i'm even
more invested because
big events don't need to happen for the
series to be able to say a lot or do
something
interesting for example in one of the
episodes rudy stages of fake kidnapping
in order to teach this tsundere lesson
because yadda yadda long story short the
kidnappers end up being real he has to
save the girl gets a sword thrown at him
and almost
dies except of course he gets saved last
minute which didn't really surprise me
or i'm sure
anyone else what did surprise me however
is the bloody decapitated corpse that
landed at rudy's feet
and for the first time rudy says nothing
no over-the-top freak out no internal
monologue just a pure
shocking look of oh [ __ ] there's a dead
body in front of me
which is such a small moment that made
me realize how much i took
something like this for granted when
i've seen similar situations happen in
other isakai stories but yeah it
says so much because despite the lighter
tones presented in early episodes this
is not some harmless jrpg world
people die people kill and it can be
brutal and rudy reacts
exactly how any one of us would react
he's a 30 year old shot and he's just
been presented with a fresh corpse in
front of him but this
chucks the pose against how casually
everyone around him acts means that this
must not really be a rare sight for this
world
so it perfectly sets up the tone for
this type of setting and what we can
come to expect in the future
it's not dark it's not edgy it's just
real
and that's what i love about the series
it's incredibly grounded despite being
set in that same cliche isekai fantasy
world we thought we knew and it says
everything it needs to without
always needing to rely on dialogue even
though it has a [ __ ] ton
of it it knows when to show and it knows
when to tell and it knows when to do a
little bit of both and even though the
setting feels so familiar to what we've
seen before
such care has been put into the way it's
constructed and presented that it's just
a treat to just inhabit it
normally i like to gloss over production
because there's not too much i can say
beyond the animation looks good and the
fight scenes are nice
and the music makes the nice noise but
there's something about this production
that just feels special in every single
aspect mashoka tensei is done by studio
bind
a completely new studio that was formed
from white fox with staff members that
seem to have a lot of experience working
on previous isekai titles and
god damn they must have brought together
the avengers of isakai staff members
because this show
looks and sounds incredible according to
interviews with producers this studio
was essentially formed
just so they could focus on mushoku
tensei which is not only insane but also
shows that someone has a lot of [ __ ]
faith in the series
the name studio binds doesn't do justice
to how good of a job they're doing
like [ __ ] me man this gets me excited
straight in my studio shaft because some
of this animation is making my studio
bone
straight up studio nut because the best
way i can put it is that this
doesn't feel like it belongs on tv you
know how you can watch an anime
franchise movie and it can at times feel
like you're just watching an extended
anime episode or a bunch of episodes
stuck together because
even if it has that slightly higher
budget it doesn't have this
big screen presence this is the opposite
of that
it's a tv series that gives off this
energy that it belongs on the big screen
and it's not just one nicely animated
scene or just one amazing moment but
something about this entire show just
gives off that vibe of a higher caliber
production that feels like it
should be encapsulated in the magic of
cinema and that's
basically mushoka tensei the only real
downside i can think of right now is
that i'm kind of scared how far this
production can go
right now the anime is confirmed for 23
episodes this year and judging by how
much of the story is taking its time
we are barely scratching the surface i'm
praying to god that studio binds are
able to adapt as much as they can
because even without reading ahead i can
already feel how much this story still
has to say and it would be a shame if it
never gets the chance to say it because
watching this show has kind of made me
fall back in love with isakai mushoka
sensei isn't just
a story about a guy reincarnated into a
fantasy world
it's a guy who's been given a second
chance to do something better and become
the person he never
could be who just happens to be
reincarnated into a fantasy world
showing us that no matter how old you
are it's never too late to make a change
in your life
it's never too late to better yourself
it's never too late
for a coming of age story and through
all the overpowered protagonists and
power fantasies and endless harems
watching this made me wonder if this was
what isekai was
always meant to be about not just
another adventure in another time
in another world but maybe just
another chance at life
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you to raycon for being today's
sponsor
question how much time do you spend
every day staring at a screen
too much well raikon wireless earbuds
may be the perfect solution for you to
take a break from designing premium
wireless audio for half the price of
other brands without compromise
six hours of play time seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass and more
raycon are doing things differently
prioritizing customer experience from
start to finish personally i love using
raycons to consume content while giving
my eyes a break like listening to
podcasts
right now i'm actually actively
listening to a new one called trash
taste which is a new podcast
i highly recommend reikon offers their
wireless earbuds in a range of fun
colors and patterns with a variety of
fit options and no
dangling wires or stems the company was
co-founded by rayjay with celebrities
like snoop dogg
and mike tyson actively using raycons
and not only that but raycon also have a
45-day
free return policy on top of all this
too so
what are you waiting for click the link
in the description or go to byraycon.com
for fifteen percent off
that's by raycon.com giga for 15
off and with that said thank you very
much too
alpha sigma basil box dysfunctional
degenerate
elephant i veto pain patch it and
everyone else my patreon for supporting
me for this month
where the [ __ ] has the time gone i swear
it was just yesterday that new season of
anime just started and
it's like the spring season is almost
starting a lot of people have been
asking if i'm going to do another
seasonal breakdown
a lot of people have been asking if i'm
going to do another seasonal stream
where i stream my reaction to all the
new anime coming out
and uh yeah i'll probably do that if you
didn't know yes
i did do that stream last season but i
don't have a final date
right now so if you want to be updated
just follow my twitter or follow my
twitch at twitch.tv
i'll tell you what though the next
season of anime has
a lot to [ __ ] live up to because my
god this season was amazing
anyway though that's it from me today no
further updates
i've been gig and i'll see you all next
time